[Music]
and we are following the latest
developments from that deadly shooting
in north las vegas we told you about at
the top of the broadcast this
investigation happening near kerry in
las vegas boulevard victoria saha has
just arrived at the scene and has an
update for us victoria
this is right in front of city of north
las vegas
51 they have the whole thing wrapped
around in crime tape but the scene is
actually right behind it you can see
investigators there working and we were
told that officers got on scene around 9
30. they found a male
unresponsive he was dead but they just
don't know how old he is we are told
that this area will be blocked off for
quite a while so if you live in this
area if you're planning on coming
towards this area you might want to find
another route again the closest cross
streets here are
mccarran and kerry we're going to be
here for a little bit the pio just got
unseen we're going to get some more
information for you guys for now i'm
reporting in north las vegas victoria
saha live local now